الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان
اله الا الله
اشهد اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
اشهد ان محمدا
حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
محمودا
بسم الله
[Arabic recitation]
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل كل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى حكايه
عن يوسف عليه السلام حينما اودعه اعداؤه
في السجن
ولبث فيه
وكان له في السجن
زميلان
وكل واحد منهما قد راى رؤيا
اهالته
فجاء الى يوسف عليه السلام
ويريدان حلا للغز
رؤياهما
فيوسف عليه السلام
استغل الفرصه
ودعاهما الى الله تعالى والى عبادته وحده
دون ما سواه
وقال
عن نعمه التوحيد
قال ذلك من فضل الله علينا وعلى الناس
الله سبحانه وتعالى
يوسف عليه السلام
without any
without any witnesses
and in that cell
الله سبحانه وتعالى
made
other
time there was not oftice being
الله سبحانه وتالى
يوسف عليه السلام
each
‏And they wanted an interpretation of
their vision
and they saw that
was the only person they had access to
and saw him as a good man who was close
to
in theirate.
‏And so they came to him asking him to
interpret their respective dreams.
[Silence]
لا اله الا الله
سبحانه وتعالى ساز
الذين امنوا ولم يلبسوا ايمانهم بظلم من
اولئك لهم الامن وهم مهتدون
سبحانه وتعالى
and those are guid
in the next
are
worship الله alone without any partners
and they do
الذين امنوا
ولم يلبسوا ايمانهم بظلم
ولم يلبسوا ان يخلطوا
ايمانهم بظلم
الظلم هنا الشرك
كما قال الله تعالى
على لساني
لقمان الرجل الصالح وهو يعظ ولده يا بني
لا تشرك بالله
ان الشرك لظلم عظيم
[Silence]
‏gra upon upon
manind
people
go
يوسف عليه السلام
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره النحل
النعم
‏name
النحل
سهم
graال
and first bless
in
‏blessing of having a disposer of our
affairs who knows all that was and all
that is to be
one who when we turn to him he is more
merful
of us than we are of our
‏than
not give us what we want but always
need
and so this blessing of
this blessing of only fearing الله alone
having trust in Allah alone
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
ir
سبحانه وتعالى
made
through
the north and south
‏Gu
our
gu
to him
to messengers
through the ages from the inception of
the moment
that the
عليه السلام
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
بحانه وى
سبحانه وتعالى
‏and commite
what said all
[Silence]
الله
فقال له اكتب
قال ما اكتب قال اكتب ما هو كائن الى يوم
القيامه
فجر القلم هنالك
بكل ما سيكون الى يوم الدين
وسطره الله سبحانه وتعالى في اللوح
المحفوظ يقول رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم وكان ذلك
قبل خلق السماوات والارض ب000
سنه
‏He says that the first thing Allah
created
of this creation
before the sun and the moon and the
this universe that we currently occupy
he created the and he said to it said
what shall I write Allah responded write
all that is going to be until the day of
judgment
the pen then wrote
ر
مقادي
صلى الله عليه وسلم وكان ذلك قبل خلق
السماوات والارض بف
الله
[Silence]
‏around us because of our
because of the limit nature of our
knowledge and understanding
we see things
as we call them near misses
just barely made it just barely didn't
make it and so we come up with this idea
of if only I had done if
‏If only this would happen. I should
have done this and I shouldn't have done
this. Not a way to learn from oures.
Out of pure agony, out of
but
removed this grief from us.
سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
make
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏are
present
صلى الله عليه
‏are by
theund
someh when something happ in
happ
someh
if i only if i hadn't done this would
have would not have
‏un
anyange
الله سبحانه وى
any
could not could
be integral
‏notuse
lainess
from ourilt
that not to us if we make a mistake
we sin we commit a sin
we wish that that didn't happ we wish
that we hadn't done
‏And we
that is that we are to look into the
we are to look into the only to draw to
better ouruture chic that's
الله سبحانه وتعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تكونوا كالذين
كفروا وقالوا لاخوانهم اذا ضربوا في الارض
او كانوا غزا لو كانوا عندنا ما ماتوا وما
قتلوا ليجعل الله ذلك حسره في قلوبهم
والله يحيي ويميت
‏ie with
suff
that
my
my myti
who went traveling passed away on
‏would
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏understand alles
of thee of no but Allah tells us enough
for us to place in Allah
for us to place our tr in to do the best
that we can and to it at that that when
something occur
‏couldn't
understand
because
عبد الله عباس
اني اعلمك كلمات
احفظ الله يحفظك احفظ الله تجده تجاهك
تعرف الى الله في الرخاء يعرفك في الشده
واعلم ان ما اصابك لم يكن ليخطئك وان ما
اخطاك لم يكن ليصيبك
‏and know that whatever does not happ to
you was never me to happ to you and
could never happen to you and
knowurtheres
you could never missed
رفعت الاقلام وجفت الصحف
صل الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
how
‏are those
free will
decree and there are those who
are extreme in their affirmation of
decree to the point that they negate the
existence of free will and the truth is
that it is a medium that is had between
the two listen to how our
صلى الله عليه وسلم
المؤمن القوي خير واحب الى الله من المؤمن
الضعيف وفي كل
‏inferior
and more to the
foundire
[Silence]
‏you to
life
and
not up
with present andut
احرص على ما ينفعك واستعن بالله ولا تعجز
ولا تقولن لشيء اصابك لو اني فعلت كان كذا
وكذا ولكن قل قدر الله وما شاء فعل فان
تفتح عمل الشيطان
if only
such and such would happree
and what
if only in
this
do
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان ينزل علينا
سكينته نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يطمئن
قلوبنا بالتوكل عليه وتقواه الا بذكر الله
تطمئن القلوب والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه
وخليله وامينه على وحيه الداعي الى رضوانه
اما بعد اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واخذل الشرك والمشركين وافضح النفاق
والمنافقين
اللهم علمنا ما ينفعنا وانفعنا بما علمتنا
اللهم اجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا ونور
صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب همومنا اللهم
علمنا منه ما جهلنا وذكرنا منه ما نسينا
وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم اننا نسالك عيش
السعداء ومنازل الشهداء ومرافقه الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء يا سميع الدعاء يا ذا
المن والعطاء والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووادلوا
حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج
الله اكبر سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك وتبارك
اسمك جتك الخير
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
غاسق اذا وقب ومن شر النفاثات
في العقد
ومن شر حاسد اذا حسد
الله اكبر
سبحان
الله
لمن حمده
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بس الرحيم
قل اعوذ برب الناس ملك الناس اله الناس
من شر الوسواس الخناس
الذي يوسوس في صدور الناس
من الجنه
والناس
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر
الله
السلام عليك السلام تبارك الجل
সলামু আলাইকুম
মিনিট first
mov 7:30 পম্মা
7:30 পমল
‏assignment whatev to the state of and
that has been increased to 362
for this year so anything that is up to
that point you can take that pay to the
masjid rather than giving it to the
state ofa so all you do you that any you
can
হডম
ইসলামিক স্কুল মেক প্রপার ইনশ্লা পজ